[Music]
in a lot of ways destiny 2 is a fresh
start
very little from the first game carries
over into its sequel including the gear
we all worked so hard to get
luckily destiny 2 makes leveling up and
finding loot in the early game
more about exploration and less about
grinding there's a lot more to do on
planets than just
quick low reward patrols and that all
starts in the european dead zone on
earth
we got to check out the edz at an event
and we'll have more gameplay coming soon
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
a thing
in destiny 1 the open world activities
you had access to at any given
destination were limited
you had patrols and you had public
events and that's about it
exploration has been greatly expanded in
destiny 2 and the first thing i noticed
when i touched down in the edz was
how many ways i had to level up and get
new gear the two most substantial
additions are adventures and lost
sectors
at first adventures seem a lot like
patrols you find them at beacons around
the map and opt into them and then a
voice crackles in through your ghosts
and gives you an objective
yellow okay speaking
but adventures are far more robust
closer to the length of a story mission
than a patrol and featuring a variety of
tasks that build upon each other as you
approach your goal
adventures also take you to different
areas of the map and often include a
healthy bit of backstory
because of that it feels like you're
doing something of substance rather than
a series of simple tasks
one adventure had me clearing out
enemies and destroying signal jammers
throughout an area
the jammers were preventing a message
from going out to any refugees from the
last city who needed to find other
survivors
though it wasn't part of the main story
it felt more important than just killing
a fallen leader in some random area of
the map
with no purpose other than to get xp and
a bit of loot but to sweeten the deal
you'll probably get some good loot for
your effort in completing adventures
lost sectors are more free-form
activities that require a sharper eye to
find
they're marked by symbols in odd spots
around the map and you have to work your
way through a mini dungeon filled with
enemies to reach a boss
beating the boss gets you loot it's
simple but it's enough of an incentive
to drive exploration
and some of the lost sectors are
surprisingly difficult to find
you could wander around the general
vicinity of a lost sector for a while
before finding the entrance tucked away
in a gap between rocks concealing an
extensive cave network below
the edz isn't necessarily bustling with
life there's one npc here devrumkay who
exchanges
loot and tokens you find around the area
for weapons and gear but adventures in
lost sectors add enough context like
more detail about the fallen or what
humanity is doing to survive to make it
an interesting world to explore
patrols and public events are still
there but variety is really the key to
revitalizing the destiny formula
they're dead we win a very good job
destiny 2 launches for xbox one and ps4
on september 6th
stay tuned to gamespot where we'll have
gameplay a review and more in the coming
weeks